all right about 10 million people they
suffer from carpal tunnel syndrome and
unfortunately it is a big problem here
in the valley where hospitality
service-based industry today happens to
be International repetitive strain
Awareness Day say that three times fast
yes exactly Dr Ryan gravo of concierge
carpal tunnel and hand surgery join me
now hands are are
shown you're in trouble oh yes it's it's
uh it's an important thing for all your
viewers to understand the reason we have
repetitive strain awareness day it
actually came from Canada in year 2000
to let people know not only employers
but also the public about the dangers of
repetitive strain injuries
um repetitive strain injuries with
carpal tunnel being the most common one
that people are aware of are industries
that come from some common problems
repetitive strain comes from repetition
lots of us in a job no matter what it's
in the service injury industry medical
personnel piping writing that's
repetition heavy Force compression to
the area awkward positions however
that's the key part of this it's not
just repetition or Force it's that we're
usually in a bad position doing things
overhead or putting our hands in a
difficult position so how do we fix it
well that's the the answer so we have a
great mnemonic so that everybody stand
up what that means is e is for
ergonomics okay make sure you're doing
it properly just like if you're working
on a computer you want your hands in a
good position right and the second one
is B for breaks you want to have
freaking breaks throughout the day
whatever you do okay that's important to
make sure that you can rest your hands
and then the next one for us is
stretching when you have those breaks
it's actually important for people to
actually stretch their arms stretch your
hands or fingers shut your hands so we
have a lot of great exercises on our
website with it a great one to start out
with is actually what we say pray for my
pain to go away and what you do is you
put your hand in this position okay and
you bring them and you just bring your
hands down and you'll feel some
stretching yeah it's like right in here
and then and then you bring your hands
towards oh the forward and you feel the
same thing this is not actually just
doing your hands but it's also doing
your shoulders and then you actually
bring it down which there's a lot of
times for Patiently it's kind of hard
it's very hard to do exactly and if
somebody has problems putting their
hands fully together any kind of
stretching is good for that and then
just making a fist opening your hands
all the way up and then you can bring
your hands out to the side making a fist
bring them in to the side back out
and then you're turning your hands all
the way in oh this is great it's all the
way out so you should be doing this
while you're taking those hair your
brakes exactly it's not just sitting
there obviously you may get some drinks
or something like that if you need water
or soda when you're taking a break from
your desk but it's really important to
actually take a break and do those
stretches yes and then the last one for
everybody stand up is understanding it's
not only our employers for understanding
that our workers need this time to do
this but us as well okay we don't know
to use their time to do that that's good
advice gosh we're running out of time
but really quickly I just want to tell
Folks at home they can find you we're
going to put your information on our
website he does the surgery of course
that's when you get to the point where
you need it but it's a new one right we
just were actually nominated well we're
actually recognizes only one of ten
centers of action excellence in the
country for Ultrasonic carpal tunnel
release thank you very much so we're the
only one in Nevada and so what's great
is it's it's done under minutes it's
under local only oh good okay yeah on
the incision size of a Tic Tac but you
know the size of a Tic Tac Dr Gray bow
such good information folks I'm gonna
I'm gonna do this as I send it over to
uh yes okay no share I am heading to
break right now Dr Grable thank you so
much it's going to be on our website
we'll be right back